i am live from the giza plateau
behind me that's brian forster right
there
oh wow
i'm gonna wait for more people to tune
in
hi there
i'm here
i made it back i hope you guys can hear
me
i'm gonna wait a few minutes for more
people to pop in
oh let's see there's brian
let's see let me see if this lets me
flip it around
there's brian forster
and this is the great pyramid of giza
egypt
look at this thing
you need to see people
to actually or on it to really compare
the size but let me just tell you guys
something real quick let me just share
some of the stats in this bad boy hi
guys i'm live from giza oh i'm like a
little kid in a candy store a little kid
on christmas hi everybody all right so
here's the deal
the great pyramid of giza egypt
is
755 feet wide at each
of its you know four bases which means
and it's nearly 500 feet tall or at
least it was during its day but
to put in comparison that means that
when you're standing at its base
you are more than 300 feet or 100 yards
to the capstone at the top or where it
would have been to the center of the
pyramid that's how big this freaking
thing is
oh my god all right see there's like 600
of us in here almost
can you guys i don't even know if you
guys can hear me
hi everyone all right so let's see here
let me
just doing this completely
improv look at this all right look at
this see this hold on guys
hold on guys forgive me
look at this thing
i'm pretty sure they're blowing whistles
at me
or somebody
i
okay let's see i don't know if i lost
the live or not can you guys are you
guys still with me
all right hi everybody
so i'm on it's four something p.m here
they're closing down the plateau for the
night
um so they're trying to kick everyone
out
now but for a bit
let's see here
any questions
any questions it looks like there's 600
of us i don't even know what to say guys
i'm like in awe that i'm out here again
the good news is is that well
unfortunately we didn't get to get out
here until just a few minutes ago
but the good news is i'll be out here
again tomorrow and then i'm going to
give you guys a tour of the plateau live
i wanted to do that today but things are
out of my control in order to get here
and so we just started late
um hi everybody
i just can't believe i'm here so let me
show you guys
all this other stuff that you haven't
seen before
i gotta be quick
i'll show you guys
[Music]
yep they're saying get down get down
oh my god
see it's even stuff like this you don't
realize are around here
until you actually walk around the
plateau itself
all these other stone works that made up
this pyramid
again there's brian foster right up
there
and you can't really appreciate the size
of this thing
until you compare it to other people and
to all you people are just tuning in i
was just mentioning a moment ago that
the pyramid is 755 feet wide at each one
of its bases
which means that
from the base up until the top
center of the pyramid is more than 300
feet or 100 yards away which makes it a
complete illusion you can't appreciate
just how big this thing is
i mean
god all right let me
flip back around here for a second
so i'll be doing this again tomorrow
because i got out here late
and they closed the plateau at 4 pm and
it's already past 4 now also they're not
letting anyone in and they're trying to
kick everyone out
but the good news is that on the tour
that i'm on we'll be out here tomorrow
around the plateau around the sphinx
around all the pyramids so
i'll be able to do a much better job
filming and getting uh showing you guys
what this is about let's see we've got
888 people that's a good number
oh wow
so let me flip this around so you guys
can see more of what i'm seeing
let's see
oh no thank you shaqran
i don't know if you guys can hear me
but let me show you guys around this
other side
oh wow
hi everybody that's just tuning in looks
like we got almost a thousand of us in
here
but i want to show you guys around this
spot real quick
hello hi say hello
hi there
oh here's a dog
you gotta be careful i'm a big animal
fan but you gotta be careful some of the
dogs out here a lot of them have fleas
hi puppy hi mama
hi there
the dogs are a little uh
skittish out here people don't always
treat them very good which just
heartbreaking
all right
wow
it's like coming out here it's hard to
even know what to say it's
overwhelming um
hi
all right so i don't know what this
stupid chain is about
let me just cross over it and show you
guys this is where they found that boat
that they dug up and now they have it
inside on the other end but this is
where that
the boat was found
big ol long boat and
just to show you guys look how close it
is to the pyramid
quite literally the nile river once
flowed right up to the steps of the
pyramid
oh my god
oh there's about 1100 of us here
you guys forgive me i don't even know
what to say i'm just so overwhelmed
i am a little sleep deprived i got into
uh the hotel last night
about
um
i don't know i'm on a few hours of sleep
jimmy doesn't
function incredibly well without a good
night's sleep
but i'm so high on life right now as
corny as that sounds they don't really
care um but here's something i really
want to show you guys so let me get my
stinking face off here
let me show you guys
first of all just look at all the ground
like everything you're seeing here is
way way way different than what it once
was
and this sucker is so big that even the
camera just you can't get it all in one
shot
but let me show you up here this is the
i forgot what they call it
but this big old platform
of
basalt
and i don't know what this thing once
was
but it was special because it's
incredibly smooth and of course this is
with
thousands of years of
erosion and weathering
but just to show you where we're at
wow
if anyone's leaving super chats i can't
really see them
but i'm very grateful if uh because
usually when i do my live streams
i do it
from a laptop and it's a lot easier to
manage
but let's see here
i think some guys are trying to prey on
me right now let's see
you got to be careful out here
the sharks of the world
hang around the giza bloodtail this
guy's been staring me the whole time if
i just think i'm some stupid american
filming
all right
oh wow that's like 1200 of us hi
everybody
so it's about 4 30 p.m or something here
on the giza plateau they're closing it
down for the evening but i'll be out
here tomorrow filming the whole shebang
let me show you guys more
there's another dog eating something but
yeah so this i don't know what this
platform once was with this black basalt
you could see just how weathered it is
and compare it to my it's my boot
um
oh i i see a super chat now but it went
away
thank you so much it's just scrolling i
don't want to screw up this live stream
but
whatever this place once was was special
and you can see the evidence of the cut
marks
here's one example
look at this
they cut these suckers and there's other
oh here you go here's an ancient
machine cut of some kind and i don't
necessarily say that it was total
machine is in like electric or anything
but this right here was not done with
bronze saw nope
it wasn't
hi there say hello
i'm jimmy
what's your name
noah oh what's that
oh
uh
no
i don't speak arabic
english only forgive me
all right let me keep going here
but and here's other stuff you guys got
to see where these blocks these stone
blocks once were
all of this cut out of the giza plateau
you have these channels where they
funneled water or whatever
and then all about you have these random
huge ass stones that were once making up
the casing of the pyramid let me
precise comparison let me show you guys
wow
it's my pleasure to film this
for you guys to see
stuff that you normally wouldn't know
existed so let me show you this these
are all fossils
so the limestone bedrock that makes up
the whole plateau was once under the
ocean however long ago millions of years
or whatever um but if you look closely
you'll see the fossils ancient fossils
the uh i think they're called
numeralites numalites something like
that i don't remember someone leave a
comment
but look at the rest of this just to
give you guys an idea what we're dealing
with here and let me is there a way to
see the super chat oh okay
jtzr1
thank you so much he said thank you for
these videos jeff in north carolina
thank you jeff
all right let me show you some other
stuff here
and again you can see all the fossils
this is all was once under the ocean
a lot of people don't realize that
here's a better shot look at all that hi
jay singh jimmy make sure you drink more
apple juice yeah i haven't had any
cocktails yet today
this evening
certainly i bet oh wow so look at this
look at this
and just to put it in perspective we're
right next to the freaking
steps of the pyramid
and look at this sucker
let me see if there's something i can
drop down here just to show you guys
the depth of it
let's see
all right look at this
okay just to show you guys what we're
dealing with here
watch this
all right the wind's picking up
look at this
you see steps down there
and where does all that go i don't know
got a nice locked gate you can't get
down there
wow
show you from this angle
and again more of those fossils see that
oh [ __ ]
drop my mic i don't know if you guys can
hear me
what do you make of that huh
wow
see
hi everybody how many we got sixteen
hundred people on your high you guys are
lovely
jimmy from the giza plateau
i'm gonna show you guys some camels
so i'm real particular you can do camel
rides out here
i won't do it because i don't like the
way they treat them they're just
basically slaves all day long
breaks my heart
livestream great idea thank you so much
and look at these blocks all right guys
you guys want to see me break the rules
so you're not supposed to go on the
other side of this rope
but you know what
jimmy needs the shot he can get mad at
me if you want to get mad at me all the
time for breaking rules
but let's see
let's see
i need the shot you guys got to see just
how big these freaking blocks are look
at this up so i'm 5'10 which is 70
inches and i think 178 centimeters or
something like that
and look how high this one is
look at this
and that's just the first
step
so let me flip this around
look at this
and the precision
oh my god see look at this precision
these are two blocks and they're like
look how close i mean you see like look
at this
can't fit anything in there hi devil
hold on who is this
forgive me if i miss some of the super
chats ron how's the energy of the place
feeling this october thank you for
taking us all along ron that was very
generous thank you very much the energy
is spectacular
absolutely wonderful it's blissful being
out here
oh my gosh
so we got 1800 people wow
look jimmy's on the outside of the ropes
needs the shot
look at this let me show you guys this
too
look at this precision these are so god
damn this thing is so big you can't even
appreciate it these are two pieces of
stone
and look at this you can't even
it's like they're glued together they're
so it's so perfect
something else to understand is that the
limestone which people say is a soft
stone well yeah it's soft compared to
granite but it is a incredibly hard
limestone
it's harder than most limestone that's
something that a lot of people don't
realize that the limestone here in giza
isn't quite as soft as other limestones
you'll find around the world all right
hold on we got another super chat here
sh mag magic trick tutorials love your
videos your videos are great thank you
so much
all right
but you see this is what i'm talking
about like it doesn't do it justice let
me flip this back around
just to show you guys
that you know when you see it through
the camera you don't realize just how
freaking big these suckers are
let's see
let me uh take off my mic real quick so
i can hang this a little bit further
i don't if you guys can hear me
oops okay
sorry if my camera work isn't the best
oh i'm having a good time guys i'm
having a very good time
and i'm out here with brian forster he's
on the other side i'll swing back over
to him it is a complete pleasure
to have traveled now to peru as well as
egypt with him i started my
exploring the ancients back in 2015 i
came across a video of him at the sarah
pm in egypt with 100 ton stone boxes
which will all be out in a few days and
i'll definitely get some great shots
there
and it's surreal to have been inspired
by him to making my own channel and then
now having traveled to these sites with
them
it's amazing how that has come full
circle
wow
this place is so
amazing
let's see where everyone is i have no
idea let me flip back around so you guys
can see what i'm dealing with here oh
well that duck took off
that dog is gone
oh no thank you
thank you
oh thank you
oh they got dogs up there barking
there's something going on that dog took
off down that way
and that's something you don't realize
that dogs live
basically on the pyramid like they go
all the way up there and they avoid
people because they're safe up there
and no i cannot climb this thing um
they'll put you in jail and find you
like 5 000 us dollars
um
wow
some camels
yeah they're kicking everyone out
someone just hooked me up with 20 bucks
thank you oh man you guys are generous
oh thank you again congrats on your
living your dream jeff in north carolina
that's the second one you did that's
very very generous of you jeff
okay hold on i think i see brian out
there what else we got here history with
kaylee what up hi jimmy excited for the
collab yeah we're totally eight guys if
you're not following
god where are these dogs going
something something's going down i don't
know what
uh if you're not following history with
kaylee get on it her channel's exploding
for a reason very talented and very what
is going on
these dogs know something
you hear them all barking
i don't know hey guys how's the the
sound
i have no idea because i'm using my
lapel mic and i just don't know
but here's another thing look at all
this like all of this was part of the
construction of the pyramid
these blocks like
makes i don't know i can't make any
sense of it
um wow i hope they're not waiting on me
guys i'm gonna do a live stream uh here
tomorrow as well because we couldn't get
out here until just a few minutes before
four
um which is a shame because the giza
plateau closes then and the plan was to
spend a couple hours doing a full tour
of all
me walking just like you see now all
around all three pyramids and the sphinx
so tomorrow i'll do that
so look forward to that
oh my god
hold on let's say hi to this dog
fuji
oh no thank you shukran say hello
yeah egyptian fan number one
i hope you enjoyed it
i love egypt
thank you much love
yes
say hello you're on youtube right now
you want to say hi
what's your name my name muhammad
muhammad i'm jimmy i'm working here at
the pyramid i have friends in america
yeah every year you come inside the
permit meditation i love it oh yeah i
love it
well thank you sir you have a good day
all i can say is wow like what else am i
supposed to say so here's the old casing
stones that still exist
flush white look at this sucker
look at all that look at the precision
i mean god look at this
wow
jimmy is a fanboy of the pyramids
i'm such a dork wow there's 2 000 people
on here you guys are wonderful
look at this though all right so i'm not
even supposed to be up here but jimmy
needs a shot
look at this
see
wow
oh my god
this place will never get old i mean
look at this i still can't get over
the tightness of these blocks look at
this oh hold on dummy
put my stupid look at this
hi doggie
hi are we leaving
okay
oh thanks for waiting
hear that guys i have
people waiting on me thanks for holding
up hey brian
mr forrester i am live on youtube right
now
what are you uh what are your thoughts
well greetings to the bright insight
fans
uh jimmy and i are getting on like a
house on fire this uh
oh hold on i don't know if you can hear
it i'm sorry okay
welcome bright insight fans jimmy and i
are getting along wonderfully he and i
spent a great period of time in peru in
august and now here we are in the giza
plateau day one
just arrived so we decided to come up
with with carlos here um say hello
carlos thank you guys right inside love
that channel
you're very kind and here it is the
great pyramid
2.5 million
multi-ton blocks
just incredible the idea that the
dynastic people built this is simply
ridiculous obviously it's an inheritance
from much much farther back in time by a
culture that had astonishing levels of
precision the alignment to north south
east and west is within something like
five arcs of one degree so it's almost
perfectly aligned
and
you have to come and see it in person
watching a video is good reading a
book's good seeing a picture is good but
standing here and looking at it
500 feet of it there's so many amazing
mysteries here that we're going to be
exploring
and also if you want to come jimmy and i
will be here again
in march
of 2022 so check in with jimmy
about how you can sign up to be with us
we're probably going to be having a nile
cruise and seeing all these astonishing
places
so
again a warm warm
welcome to all of you all of the
1.1604 million fans that he has
and check him out on instagram
and youtube and it's an honor to be
traveling with him once again
brian you're a total gentleman
it's absolute pleasure to be traveling
with you
i was just sharing a moment ago that
brian was one of my main sources of
inspiration i was a fan of the egyptians
since sixth grade when we were taught
about it in school
and then there i was in 2015 depressed
i've shared this story before
and i started going down the rabbit hole
of the egyptians and i came across some
interesting
information that suggested that we
really have no idea how they built this
stuff and that the theorized
methods such as for how they constructed
it the cutting of the stone bronze saws
and
chisels and stone ammers
it's debunked it's not how they did it
i'm not suggesting they were more
advanced than us although maybe i'm
quite open-minded to that but the point
is that it is a real mystery and then
there i was on the couch and i came
across a video of brian foster at the
crp and with 100 ton stone boxes which
will be out on sunday
and uh yeah it's surreal to be traveling
with them and as i was sharing a few
moments ago
what's one thing that's so incredible
about this pyramid is you don't realize
so it's 755 feet wide at each of its
four bases
and nearly so it's 480 feet tall or so
or was it its prime which means that
from the base
to the top center
is more than one or excuse me 300 feet
or 100 yards away from us
and so it's quite
it's very deceiving it's a it's an
illusion almost because it's so big you
don't realize that what you're looking
at now used to be a 47-story building or
equivalent it's
wild
um so they want us out of here now we
got to get going
all right everybody hold on actually let
me i'll keep filming with you guys to
show you kind of like the area but i'm
gonna do this tomorrow um we didn't get
out here until four just a few minutes
before 4 p.m and they closed down
and um
so the plan was to do a complete tour of
the giza plateau but i'll do that
tomorrow so be looking forward to that
but i'm going to stay live here until
i'm out here because i'll even if it's
just showing you the entrance in and out
of this place you'll be learning
something new hold on we've got more
dogs running around
where are they going
wow
wow wow wow but let me show you
i'm gonna film all the way up until we
kick our butts out of here but you got
this let's see who's leaving a super
chat you guys are so wonderful forgive
me for missing some of them but i'll be
able to read them later but
i mean just look at this all this used
to be something and this is just what's
left of it
unreal
right there's the entrance
you can see a little where they blew it
out with dynamite
above it was the original entrance
down yonder you can't see it we got the
other pyramids and the sphinx but
tomorrow i'll show you all right i got
to get going there
i hate holding people up
wow we got 2 200 people on here
oops hold on here
hi everybody i hope you guys can hear me
bye now mohammed it was a pleasure
gentlemen oh no thank you no no shukran
no thank you thing i appreciate it thank
you so much
very grateful hello oh let's let's get
this
got to be careful on these camels they
don't like us hi there
oh it's all right hold on let me let me
go like this
yeah oh it's okay
hello
you gotta be careful on these camels
they don't like us one bit you're
beautiful though
they'll spit on you
yeah oh yeah bite yeah
you got to be nice to them
oh no i appreciate it
yeah next time i actually pick you i
don't want to ride these camels i feel
bad they're
they're used all day and i just i'm an
animal lover and it's not to say i
haven't ridden a horse so maybe i'm a
big hypocrite
but the horse
liked it the horse was excited it wanted
to be ridden some horses do some horses
don't but someone sounds like a big
hypocrite and some animal rights warrior
although i am i mean like you know [ __ ]
sea world for example um
and [ __ ] marineland
anyways what am i talking about i'm out
here in giza
all right so let me turn this around and
show you guys more of what i'm looking
at here so this is how you get up here
like there's the road big circle
you can see over there to the second
pyramid or allegedly the pyramid of uh
caffrey it's not his pyramid this is the
chi ups pyramid
i guess
oh he's sir at this car
[Music]
oh look at these commando dudes over
around here
oh wow
look like they're getting ready to do
some freaking raid
they must got word that jimmy's in town
should i go pester these people what are
they doing
wow brian i'm still live security
yeah
god these guys are no joke do you think
it'll be mad if i go up and film them
should i not do that uh no i wouldn't
leave them alone
yeah
i mean these guys look like they're
literally well whatever
major
carlos you are live what's your
impression it's your first time here in
giza now you just stepped foot next to
the pyramids for the first time ever
what do you think oh i'm sorry
i mean it's just the size is just so
tremendous you know you walk in and it's
it's like a giant mountain of stone uh
just sitting there and the size of it is
just
unbelievable
um did it surprise you like as far as
the uh i mean having saw it and you know
in pictures and videos and now you're
here in person was there anything that
surprised you
yeah bigger in person or yeah just the
sheer size of it you know and and
and and actually the stone is a lot
harder than i thought uh when you first
see it in the in on you know pictures or
whatever you see it kind of kind of a
lot of um erosion and you think oh you
can just peel it off or you can just
scrape it off but no you can't the stone
is super hard
um which makes sense though because if
it's lasted this long you know through
millennia then it makes sense that it
would just be super solid and and that's
why it's lasted so long so yeah the the
the erosion makes you think it's a lot
sort of uh softer but it's not it's it's
very very hard stone yeah let me uh i i
appreciate you bringing it up that's
something i was just mentioning here we
should let's get walking i feel we're
holding everyone up
that's one of the points i was
mentioning a few minutes ago
was that the limestone
of giza
is much harder than most limestone
anywhere else and as carlos was just
pointing out i mean it's it feels like
granite and it's not far off like a lot
of people say oh it's a very soft stone
like well
limestone compared to other stones sure
is soft but this is hard as hell
um brian are you familiar with like the
the hardness of the limestone we were
just discussing on how this limestone is
far harder than
yeah that's true i mean most people
think that the limestone core
of the great pyramid is simply calcium
carbonate which is actually quite soft
it's about three on the mohs scale but
you it's very difficult to attempt to
try to scratch the surface of this so
it's obviously a much
harder
material a type of limestone with a lot
of different
uh chemicals and salts and things in it
but much much harder than a standard
limestone that you would find in a
quarry in the u.s so again the
difficulty of cutting these blocks
transporting them setting them into
place almost perfectly monumental task
beyond the capability likely of us today
or it would cost billions of dollars so
you know it's one of the great mysteries
of the world it's the last surviving
ancient of the seven wonders of the
world
and so it's again it's just it's an
honor to be here once this is trip
number nine
obviously not gonna be the last one i'll
be back with jimmy in march of next year
so sign up at hidden inca tours or
through jimmy or through the chem at
school
and god bless you all from giza
hi there hello everybody
you on youtube hello
so let me show you guys one last thing
as we're walking out of here so if
you're wondering what the view looks
like from the giza plateau into cairo
cairo
is absolutely massive metropolitan it's
estimated between 21 and 24 million
people and it's
skyrise condo
after one after the other i don't know
if this is this isn't doing it justice
because it looks further away than it is
but it is simply huge and it's people
all over the place
um hi there
what's up oh i'm i'm filming right now
buddy hold on you want to say hello
you're on youtube say hi
what's up
what's that youtube
oh all right type this is funny type in
bright insight um oh i i don't know the
letters uh english okay b
r i g h t
you better you better hit the subscribe
button
um oops oh i'm sorry
right and then inside how do you do
space
or bright no
this is hilarious say hi buddy you're
you're you're on camera uh do us i need
one more word bright insight
[Music]
are we leaving
i'm trying to make one type in bright
insight
what's your name
right all right one more
his name is ahmed ahmed yes very good
name
right in sight
hi everybody this is hilarious
right inside
oh hi buddy let's go there
pleasure to meet you that's fun we
should go now okay thank you so much oh
say hello
yeah akeem akeem ayan right oh yeah
this is yusef's nephew
joseph's
yeah
all right guys so i got 2 400 people on
here right now which is awesome but guys
are kicking us out of giza so i'm going
to do this tomorrow we'll be traveling
around the plateau so i'm going to go
live again the intention was to do it
today but we couldn't get out here until
late unfortunately so it is what it is
but then i'm gonna i'll do this tomorrow
i'm gonna walk around we're gonna go
around all the pyramids right
and
this sphinx as well
and so i'll go live again then
god this is someone was asking earlier
what the vibe is the energy's like out
here guys it's freaking spectacular look
at this
and you don't realize just how spread
out all this stuff is i mean look how
far away the second pyramid is
um
my god
let's see here
wow
all right everybody i guess i'm going to
close this up actually no i'm going to
keep going and i'm going to show you
what this place looks like on the way
out every little thing
will teach you something
you haven't seen
um then you before
show off the hotel it's very nice oh
yeah so we're staying at the marriott
mina house which is walking distance
from here it's absolutely lovely
yeah you see these steel up this place
pretty good um are we walking back or
car yeah oh good all right i'm just
gonna stay live guys yeah i'm going to
show you guys what all this looks like
that's where you pay
to get a ticket in
it's 200 egyptian pound which is like i
don't know what is that like 20 bucks 15
us dollar goes quite far here guys it's
a approximately 15 to one ratio
for us dollar to egyptian pound so you
can come out here and live like a king
um
yeah
i'm just gonna keep filming
wow
i'm feeling good my knees holding up no
issue there
so those you aren't aware i have a
broken knee i got a bone chip floating
around in there which is lovely it
hasn't locked up yet so we're doing all
right
what are you guys saying any uh
questions or comments i haven't been
able to see the chat so uh
let's see here
all right
not get hit by a car
hello say hello
hi there
nope okay
hold on guys
hold on i unplugged my
do you have cash with you
no but hold on here dang it hold on
hold on
sorry about that just had unplugged my
thing yeah you say they don't want you
to film them
all right here we go hold on
leaving giza walking back to the meena
house the mean house is a seriously nice
hotel it's i tell people like how like
how nice is it well it's where obama
stayed in 09 and other celebrities and
dignitaries of other countries that's
where they all go and it's the closest
hotel to the plateau
all right let me show you guys what i'm
seeing instead of getting my face on
here looks like we got a lovely old uh
junkyard covered in dust
over there was a golf course i don't
think it is anymore
um
and this is the street heading back
oh we got 2 22 people on right now 2 2 2
2 that's a really good number i'm in
numbers guys
yep i'll just keep filming show you guys
exactly what this setup looks like out
here what it takes like because when you
guys come out here someday to the giza
plateau you'll already have an
understanding of what to expect
wow
got mr brian forester
anyone have any questions or
comments
let's see i want to go i'm trying to
read some of these here junkyard of cars
yeah i mean that's literally what that
is
the ancients would be proud of
us right
kind of a pity
look at that kid whipping that poor
donkey i don't know if you can see it
he's whipping the hell out of it you
hear it yeah i don't know if you can
hear it he's whipping that thing
ugh
he breaks my heart i don't know if you
guys can see that
that kid must be
eight years old
wow
all right i'm just gonna keep filming we
got brian forester here so that's
another thing that you guys will love so
i was just telling you you guys were
just talking to carlos one of the
funnest things about going on these
tours
is the friendships you make instantly
people from all over the world we got a
bunch of different countries of people
here
and
you know you're all like-minded people
especially people that are willing to
travel at this period of time in the
world
when the world's gone crazy a lot of
people aren't traveling
and
so the type of people that would come
out besides the fact that you already
have a connection as far as an interest
into the ancients
um
the fact that you know other like-minded
people you make friends super easy and
friends you'll have forever all right
let me show you guys what i'm seeing and
then i'm gonna have to end this chat i
guess we're gonna get into the car are
we driving back or walking
we're driving all right we're so close
we don't even need to
but uh
look what i'm seeing
all right i'm getting into the little
cat taxi i don't know why because the
mean house is right over there i mean
that's part of the building right there
actually
all right guys so i'm going to wrap this
up
i'm jimmy channel is called bright
insight i love you all i'll be going
live from here tomorrow when we'll have
a full tour of giza we didn't we weren't
able to get out here until late uh and
giza closes at four
and so they finally kicked us all out so
tomorrow with the whole tour we'll be
going around the plateau around the
pyramids and the sphinx i'll film and
show you guys more of the things to see
but i love you all i'm gonna cancel out
or close it out here but i'll see y'all
tomorrow
how do i stop